hey everyone persia here and we are back
with another roundup of community clips
this week's game is the one and only
fortnite if you want to learn how you
can submit your own clips then stay
tuned to the end of this video but in
the meantime
make sure you like and subscribe before
we get started
[Music]
oh
[Music]
bro please come home
[Laughter]
[Music]
dude i wish my shotgun like i have more
bullets or something
no that's great
[Music]
folks way back east had nothing to say
[Music]
ah
[Music]
uh
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
wait i'm gonna one pump these kids send
me them oh my god if you hit this
wait can i jump out of the chicken
midair it might be worth
i don't know
100 wait oh my god you don't take fall
no
not if you throw the chicken down
so
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
hey everyone thank you so much for
watching and of course if you've made it
this far then you probably want to know
how to submit your clips
for next week a few things to keep in
mind is that it doesn't just have to be
fortnite we're looking for
all types of clips if you had fun if you
had a hype moment well
we want to see it how can you submit it
well you just gotta tag me on twitter at
persia underscore xo or
at gamespot so we can take a look here's
my personal favorite submission from
last week
all right everyone hope you enjoyed make
sure you like
subscribe and we'll see you next time
[Music]
peace
[Music]
do
[Music]
you